[Musique]
en
bonsoir et que je bord et sur les
planches
en costume de gala
mesdames se bat mais je déclenche
ans
instantanément la furia gens donnent une
réponse italienne
dégoulinant de cominar je suis ragga
démarre en guerre
mais aussi vos gueules que moi citoyen à
coder cathy me casanova les mamies avant
vous tentez là si c'est lui la prothèse
auditive dans le pôle de gériatrie
l'ambiance tourne à l'hystérie je suis
un dandy à couleur abricot débreake
[Musique]
une telle ambiance de dingue
jo
[Musique]
j'exige mais forcera tish un sourire
d'un leader
[Musique]
le post
sa tenue n'est éternel au sommet du col
[Musique]
enfant d'un bouquin
[Applaudissements]
fermez les yeux et imaginez vous pouvez
en mandat ou s'il allait contrôler tout
ça
[Musique]
derrière la danse est le chevalier sans
cela prend plaisir à se déshabiller
je songe à sa beauté qu'elle cache un
grand gala et songe à son souhait de
l'art est ma raison c'est gagnant le
sens où elle a selon elle ouvre toi
je tourne le dos lorsque je la crois que
ça va moi la ville et sa cambrure le
condamné deux fois de plus à la torture
sans le sou et là
[Musique]
dès que chez nous à terre de rire est un
calvaire en chemin de croix
cent soldats
je ne sais pas pourquoi relisez mon
martin semble te divertir plus elle
s'inscrit
y
[Musique]
on
la peau ne sont souhaitées le parfum de
miel je le prends et je maudis le ciel y
s'obstinant à me priver d'un technicien
chat d'infliger le pire les supplices
[Musique]
un texte
j'explique enlèvent leurs défauts des
bébés chez tandis que la passion peut
condamner au bûcher sens mais la belle
averse de son éventail attise le feu qui
consume les entrailles
sans cela j'écoute mois et de jeu nous
étaient 2000 est un calvaire
je me crois son souhait là où elle s est
battue va votre genou martyrs semble de
dire très sensible
[Musique]
c'est vraiment super on est comme ça en
france
on
voyez mon pauvre que la paix de ben brik
venez son agonie dans les rues de
séville pratiques et détournements
galope a fait subir
je songe à me noyer dans le bundle c'est
moi qui chante
moi si c'est pour dire dalkia molle fuir
bientôt je passerai une série à trépas
que tous ces marques seraient jusqu'à la
giralda et je vous aiderai ce mec mais
joie et ont sombré dans une dernière
fois sont soit sous la cendre
[Musique]
aïe
[Applaudissements]
ce sont probablement mourir alors je ne
suis pas le seul représentant culturel
de la ville de montmorillon il y avait
aussi régente de forges
[Musique]
je reviens demain embryons c'est la
meilleure chose à faire quand vous allez
là bas
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
je lui proposais s'asseoir au salon à la
demande et à une série a brandi comme le
sommet s'était plutôt bien parti j'ai
enfilé la populaire de la grippe sont
ces jouets eddie cochran du lyonnais
orient qui sont proposés l'enseignement
ans à l'étude c'est à ce moment là n'est
pas la bonne façon de les régler mais
non
[Musique]
maintenant non
j'étends dillon le repas de réveillon
lorient 7 et siebel qu'après les
coquillages au second j'ai ressorti mon
instrument de son aiguille jardins
historiques et tutti frutti
j'ai enfilé la bandoulière et maggie
sans jamais me konaté mais par où c'est
à ce moment là est en deuil habitent à
rétablir est nommé à beni hammad accents
de john ging
dans moi la dinde de thanksgiving mais
non plus n'a pas été sans ambages sa
part l'élu lobbying dix ans dans les
règles son brushing même un an
maintenant
ça balance citepa nemechek denver post
on doit gérer avec les pieds à la sauce
qui nous illustrons si l'emblème à toi
c'est au rayon suis dit tu me les
excellents dans son étui center new year
est acquis le sens tu peux aller des
sentiers acquis en flac était dans ce
texte français pas la belge rtbf
tennessee si tu parles vous voulez avec
l'accent du mérite
le moment rien c'est pas mon père c'est
pas loin
elle émettra pour la rime oui ça faisait
un jeu de mot avec le pire est plié
[Musique]
merci beaucoup de votre accueil
je vous laisse avec michelin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]